[Music]
this is a period of great transition
it's a seismic shift
of foot maybe the biggest revolution
since we moved from the horse to the
engine if i say electric vehicle today
many people think of one name
but many startups want to change that
rivian lordstown
fiska lucid and canoe are all in a race
to release new vehicles
and it's going to get to be a pretty
crowded space in 2020 four out of five
evs sold in the us were teslas and most
of the others were made by traditional
automakers
as analysts project that the market for
evs will grow 140
by 2026 new contenders are pitching
themselves as the next
big thing and they have one thing in
common we haven't sold a single car
even though they haven't produced
market-ready cars yet they've secured
millions sometimes billions of dollars
in funding but their strategies are very
different and car analysts say not all
of them will survive
there's probably a little too many ev
startups right now
there's a whole bunch of other warner
bees out there that exists because of
tesla
who have no concept that this is a
technology race so how are these
companies trying to win the great ev
race
investors have collectively pumped over
10 billion dollars into these companies
with rivian receiving the most some 8.2
billion dollars of investment coming
from
ford amazon and blackrock we asked to
speak to rivien's ceo but the company
said they wanted to wait until they'd
started production
lucid is second with some 7.4 billion
dollars
we're now in a very secure financial
position
and and it's up to it's up to management
not to screw this up
that's peter rawlinson looted ceo the
company recently received more than two
billion dollars through saudi arabia's
public investment fund and also received
4.6 billion dollars through a merger
with a special purpose acquisition
company or spac
spanx are essentially empty shell
companies set up with the sole purpose
of raising money to merge with another
business and then take that business
public
fisca too has seen some one billion
dollars injected into the company
through its spac merger with apollo
global management
henrik fisker is fiska's ceo i think
that's great news for for everybody for
us
and for customers that are looking for
new type of vehicles new technologies
etc
lords town and canoe have both received
less funding under one billion dollars
each
but those investors are betting on
vehicles targeted at very different
customers
ones that aren't necessarily going to
compete against each other
lucid is trying to capture the top end
of the market with its high-end
luxury 169 000
lucid air dream edition its ceo knows a
thing or two about sedans i led the
design of
engineering of model s tesla's premium
it's not true luxury
we see a huge space in the luxury ev
space they
might have some more challenges because
you look at those 150 000 vehicles
and you know they're pretty established
but at the other end of the market is
fiska
they're making an suv called the ocean
which will sell for between
35 and 70 thousand dollars it's made
partly with recycled material
i think most eevee startups start with a
sports car luxury car because they kind
of need to prove
that they can make a cool car so they
feel that this is necessary for them to
do i don't think we need to prove that
i truly think the next frontier is
affordability
value for money and getting high volume
uh into the market of evs lordstown
canoe and rivian are also targeting the
utility vehicle segment by developing
pickup trucks
and this microbus if you want to
have a bit of a chance really you kind
of need to get into that utility vehicle
segment because that's what consumers
are buying however
everybody's getting into the utility
vehicle segment because that's what
consumers are buying
before selling these vehicles to
consumers these startups first need to
make them
and some of them say they've been held
up by the coronavirus pandemic and
supply chain issues
they've missed a lot of their goals
they've missed a lot of their targets
they do jump in
thinking it's going to be a little bit
easier than it is or that they can move
it faster
than they can and they get into it and
realize
that there are just elements you can't
rush
when tesla began production of their
model s they decided to move almost all
parts of manufacturing in-house
and lucid is doing exactly the same
tesla's in the preeminent position
because it has hardcore technology
in-house
that is why it's worth what 650 billion
dollars and other companies
aren't rivien and lordstown meanwhile
have acquired former automotive
manufacturing facilities
but companies like canoe and fiska are
instead outsourcing their manufacturing
to other companies
most companies don't get it they think
doing an ev
is you just buy all these parts off the
shelf and you close them together in a
frankenstein and that's a battery ev
we are less interested in sort of this
ego trip of having to show everybody
else you can manufacture a car
normally what car industry does is they
bring a new car into an existing factory
with very trained personnel
to avoid any hiccups and that's
essentially what we're doing
when these vehicles do eventually come
to market you'll be hard-pressed to buy
one in a traditional car dealership
like tesla most of these startups plan
on selling direct to the consumer but
fiscal and canoe said they would also
offer subscription models much like some
other ev companies do in china
we see a lot of people specifically a
lot of younger people are really
interested in this
because a lot of young people really
don't want to go and borrow 50 000
euros lordstown on the other hand is
hoping to target fleet operators with
its pickup truck
these vehicles won't only be competing
against tesla
there's also many startups in countries
like china
and of course there's the legacy car
industry they are also competing against
the traditional automakers and let me
tell you they're
woken up and they're serious and they're
not messing around
a lot of the things that were considered
disruptors are very rapidly
filtering through the industry for any
kind of vehicle you want to buy
which means the startups don't
necessarily have that unique proposition
general motors said it's investing 27
billion dollars in evs and autonomous
driving
it plans to make 30 electric models by
2025
and is spending 2.2 billion to convert a
factory in detroit into its new ev hub
this is a change in trajectory for
society
and for general motors other car makers
are actually betting on the startups
succeeding
ford for example has invested some 500
million dollars into rivian
but fisker and lucid are both betting
that they can replace some of those
automakers within the next decade
i think we're going to say goodbye to a
few of the traditional car companies
that just won't even be there in 10
years and then i think you're going to
see some
of those traditional car companies maybe
sort of
shrink and become smaller that change of
the order of the guard has already
commenced
but there's going to be a continuation
of that over the next decade
i think that there's going to be blood
on the carpet